we're gonna have a good time to the sky
we got a sparkle I'm counting down
feels like I've been walking
[Laughter]
good morning Lenny
welcome back to the morning toast day 3
a 4 day 4 in our new studio what a crazy
week it's been I know it's been a roller
coaster but it's day 4 it's actually our
last live show of the week because
Claudia's going to Kansas City tomorrow
you'll get a podcast only episode later
in the day Robin's going to Kansas City
she's performing at the Midland Bank
theater tickets available at Carl's no
job calm they're almost sold out I can't
wait to see all the Kansas City toasters
I just say there's something about the
Kansas City toasters we might need to
take a trip Jackie because more so than
ever like before any show I always get
like tweets like seeing girl in job
tomorrow but I'm getting like the nicest
most emotional tweet you know why I
think it is because you probably don't
remember this but you once said that you
like you wouldn't be taking your tour to
Kansas City because yeah like on the
first leg of the tour you're like I'm
going everywhere and then but I'm not
going to Kansas City like oh yeah and
then they revolted and that's the reason
I'm going so they're just feeling extra
grateful that you you know added this
stop on the tour I think you know like
people are tweeting me that they just
like loved the show so much like it's
changed our lives they like loved the
confidence it gives them like the family
values like and I just think maybe
people in Kansas City are really nice
this is such a Family Values show you
should be on HG know on the Hallmark
Channel like well because we're so
family what's that show they have they
have a talk show home and hearth know
they have a talk show like yeah the home
the family chat whatever yeah I know but
like with our swear words oh yeah and
yeah we're not a Hallmark friendly but
we should be on the ABC Family well that
doesn't exist anymore those way to do
free or those were the days I'm free for
bits like ABC Family's like naughty
older sister freeform [ __ ] is really ABC
family grew up and now she's like an
angsty teen wears lots of eyeliner
hundred percent she got her nose pierced
see the special guest in the studio Jay
you probably hear him clanking around in
his clankers it's t-h-e oh I don't want
to say his name as to alert him but he's
in the house being incredibly C ute and
we're really excited to have the CR u n
CH boy here today yes very very exciting
if you're watching live I hope you're
rejoicing because we believe we have
gotten rid of our white noise problem
the hissing that was occurring in the
audio is no longer with us we said
goodbye to her this morning it was sad
because she's been such a part of the
new studio no it's honestly like I miss
her yeah no separation anxiety is real
but I think it's for the best you know
separation anxiety Israel and so am i
we're moving on up we have this frog
hopefully it helps with the podcast
rodeo but visually speaking we're
actually gonna switch it up for so just
like we said every day will be little
tweaky vibes here at the morning toast
thanks for you know being patient with
us every day something's gonna change I
cannot wait for our couches to get here
yeah if you want to punch into my solo
cam today I have my little desk I'd like
a work desk next to my seat because I
have the baskets at the gabbles ever my
phone I have our podcast sponsors yeah
and you and you have the smokestacks the
what oh the smokestacks behind me which
I thank God because God I'm just feeling
so industrial today and I don't you know
that like our smokestacks are working
for us what is a smokestack I don't know
but I'm smokestack yeah ya know by the
way pretty soon those are gonna be big
jewels they're vaping over there now I
say I feel like it's like pollution
going on behind me like we shouldn't be
excited about it Oh totally morning I
don't think we have that much to catch
up on today like what'd you do yesterday
what did I do when we announced camcos
ticket man scam toast tickets I got a
hydro facial yesterday so have to wear a
little bit less makeup today but I feel
like my skin is definitely better off
for it we recorded a great podcast
episode for the patreon last night with
Olivia all about her pregnancy and it's
honestly really cute really informative
and really relatable I feel be relatable
it was really fun it's like the only
time I ever get to see my family is when
we're podcasting like right and that's
why I keep up with my sister's it's
honestly great um we got our own podcast
filter I mean Instagram filter yeah but
it's not working yet so like that's not
no run yeah no right no man you'll see
you'll know when you know and then we
will had to watch four hours of
television so that we yeah because I had
to watch last week's Jersey because I
didn't want to watch it get hyped up and
have to wait another week and because it
was a to be continued
so I was glad that I had them together
but then I didn't realize Dallas was on
and then of course I had to watch watch
what happens live oh I didn't want to
rush what happens live but I did watch
their major announcement um that's
Neil's tablets leading the franchise for
good you know what goodbye I know but
you know what it was weird because she
came on she was like I will never be a
housewife again it's like no offense
sweetie I'm in housewives in 6 2011
right so it's like Amana news it was so
strange him wasn't she supposed to be
the Duchess of Sussex like yeah she's
okay to that guy Oliver I was so
disgusted by her behavior I'm not sure
is he like Margo Joseph's is my hero I
was like I actually had a physical pit
watching New Jersey last night and
Dallas like Devils was horrible so there
was just so much pit inducing content
and we will talk about it at the end of
this yeah we're gonna recap Dallas and
Jersey been watched Dallas with me and
he was like he knows like the drama and
he was like so invested because this is
like the type of conversation we've
never had in a friend in a Housewives
franchise and it's just fascinating yeah
it's really really fascinating we'll get
to it I don't want to start the show
talking about it because it's just like
no and so much happened yesterday that
we must discuss oh my god so much news
today guys I had to whittle it down to
five stories it was tough so these truly
are the Fast Five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast they are
for sure I don't think that's factually
incorrect of you to say but I do think I
would be I would be so upset I think I
would be remiss honestly I would be
devastated I might even be not to be
dramatic but like heartbroken I think I
would have a strong strong case of RDH
if I didn't let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by OkCupid
have you ever been on a date where you
met just had nothing in common with the
person a lot of people don't know this
but okay Cuban has really changed the
dating game I asking you tons of
questions about yourself and what type
of person you're looking for I know
you're married but like you actually had
a very robust dating history and bestest
hell from like the apps to all the going
to bars and I feel like you are it could
actually if these walls could talk yeah
they'd say a lot I'm a big dating a
proponent if you're not on a dating app
you are not in the game and OkCupid is
dating app is where it's at because
they've so many more questions than a
traditional service the more questions
you answer the better they are at
finding you matches and people you have
a lot in common with
so they have a lot of interesting
questions not just like what are your
hobbies are you a morning person do you
make new year's resolutions that's a
great question and also a great
conversation starter on a date
could you take you can judge someone so
hard by their new year's resolution of
course like stop your leg soda if you
have any they also ask could you date
someone that's that couldn't be bothered
to vote like more serious stuff what's a
bigger deal sharing your bed or your
history in bed very emotional questions
OkCupid are you a cord cutter ooh could
you date someone who didn't believe in
reproductive rights yes true do you
share your streaming platform passwords
with other people those are the real
questions or are you someone who takes
out their pre those passwords the best
part about OkCupid is that it works very
simply it's the most mentioned dating
app in the New York Times wedding
section oh that's so interesting
you can stop the mindless time on dating
apps and go to the app where you choose
what matters OkCupid is free so we don't
even have to give you one of those super
long websites with a code just download
okay keep it in the app store today go
on a great date this week and then tell
us about that great person you met will
come to the wedding
we might even officiate and yeah you
know what I'm saying it right here right
now if you meet someone on OkCupid
because you were inspired to download
this app I will attend and perform at
your wedding I also feel as though
January is a great time to like try
something new put yourself out there
meet someone on OkCupid sign on and find
love agreed agreed
okay let's get right into it because
there's one story that just Trump's all
the other stories it's a history-making
story I'm hooked to the [ __ ]
core I actually saw a story about this
in page six yesterday before the show
that there were rumors that Megan and
Harry we're gonna leave the royal family
and I was like oh there's ha that's
impossible she would never she worked so
hard
meanwhile Megan and Harry are leaving
the royal family yeah it's so crazy the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex release on
their Instagram a statement of very long
steaming yesterday I'm gonna read some
of it after months of reflection and
internal discussions we have chosen to
make a transition this year in starting
to carve out a progressive new role
within this institution we intend to
step back as quote senior members of the
royal family and work to become
financially independent while continuing
to fully support Her Majesty the Queen
that's
crazy financial independence is so
interests aunt because how they gonna
make money I mean is she gonna go back
to acting right and now this kind of
just makes me feel like all along this
was her master plan like she became she
couldn't get famous being an actress so
she became the biggest celebrity in the
world but honestly being a royal like
low-key sucks you had to do a lot of
like boring stuff and you can't like put
your purse on the floor so now she just
gets to move back to North America I
heard they're moving to Toronto and like
I heard I mean like Melanie Bromley is
at it I just think like this could have
been her plan all along I don't I don't
I'm so confused this doesn't jive with
what like when you want to be a princess
you don't become a princess and then
renounce the criticism you know and but
just on the princess yeah of course but
on the other hand it kind of makes sense
because even it's like how the Queen's
other kids other than Charles are not
senior members of the royal family one
because it's Prince Andrew but then
there's two other kids who are you know
kind of irrelevant other grandchildren
who aren't really part of the core
family and Harry is kind of irrelevant
to the succession of course and so he
doesn't really need to be a senior
member no they did this because they can
William and Kate could never do this no
no that would be him abdicating right
he's like royal lineage should be honest
like he was honestly in the worst
position because he has to do all the
Royal [ __ ] he can't really have fun
and he'll never be king but to me like
the Royal [ __ ] seems fun it seems
fun to you but like everyone talked look
at Diana like everyone talks about how
like the pressure living in the palace
like all like the rules like it can
really get you and I totally get how
like Megan probably really wanted to be
famous and really wanted to be princess
and then she got it and it [ __ ]
sucked I don't know why cuz some people
are born for it like I know some people
are born into it some people are born
for it like Kate Middleton was born to
be royal like I don't think she's
bothered by the rules I think she loves
you know the history and I think some
people are made for it and then some
people are just not and I don't think
Megan oh I think Megan is made for it
but see I look at it now from two
different angles like now it like makes
me think that all the rumors of them not
getting along and her being like a diva
like kind of like have to be true well
then also then Buckingham Palace
released a statement saying that they
didn't know that the Duke and Duchess
were about to release a statement like
these are complicated matters and
and apparently everyone is in a tizzy
like yeah this they just like kind of
went off the deep end with this watch as
they dive in yeah so I'm so I'm so shook
honestly it's so crazy like there's just
a lot going on there and it's just
annoying because like so many people are
so invested but we'll never get an
answer I think we'll get an answer in 20
years we're gonna answer me be even in
five years if it's on the crown I need a
biopic yeah yeah I need the crown to
catch up sad I don't watch the crown oh
my god I'm not gonna recommend it for
you because I don't think that you would
have the patience for it but if you ever
did it's so great it seems a little
boring I'm not gonna lie what else did
the statement say um just you know that
they're gonna spend part of their time
in the UK and North America all right do
you think they're gonna move to like
Calabasas that would be so like like she
just like I just think where they move
will say a lot about what their
intentions are I feel like they'll
either move to New York Toronto I guess
they're definitely now gonna be at the
Met Gala they're gonna be like George in
a mall you know jeoldae like
international socialites yeah you know
but I'm happy for them honestly if if I
could be an international socialite I
would definitely want to be one so I'm
happy for them know that I am I'm
confused for them I'm worried about
Queenie vibes like she's holding on to
this monarchy like grasping and she does
she does all the work you know she's a
hundred years old she works so [ __ ]
hard so the grandkids can't stay in line
like if I were her I would be so [ __ ]
frustrated also I think this whole
situation would be less weird if we
didn't find out that Buckingham Palace
had no idea like that's where the shud a
better in-law vibes are coming from I
don't know if they had no idea but like
they weren't ready for the statement Oh
ma'am you know they went wrote you know
we have like a new I'm like sound board
that where you like play sounds we
should have a sound of shed a better
in-law saying hey any time we say shed a
better and wha yeah wouldn't that make
you feel
spooky it wouldn't I just this is a
history making stuff here this would be
a tank it reminds them of the king who
like abdicated the throne and Wallis
Simpson a divorcee from America and I
don't think it's that extreme because
Harry wasn't in line for the crown you
know and like they're not Nazis this
will have no bearing on history because
like you said Harry is irrelevant in
terms of lineage it's just like gossipy
like it's crazy it's crazy I'm just
really happy that Megan's gonna be able
to put her purse on the floor like I
just I know that that's bothering her I
can't explain it it's just like the
massage she's like such a feminist
remember how she wrote you know a letter
to the Cascade commercial not cascade to
the dishwashing commercial that showed a
woman doing dishes like she is a
born-again feminist and I just think
like some of these roles are a little
antiquated for her but she was she
wasn't making change from within no she
wasn't
I just can't believe it she came so far
like from Hallmark to the palette know
from like a set of Buckingham Palace to
the real [ __ ] it's incredible it to
the gates outside Buckingham Palace
to the bedroom inside great such an
incredible story and then just to leave
it all behind well for a life in Toronto
honestly maybe going back to suits
I like truly it was they're gonna they
said they made it a point to say the
financial independence like nobody was
really asking about money do you think
so Harry's gonna get a job yeah what is
he gonna do it Wall Street I don't know
I feel like he could be a salesman for
something like the watches I just feel
like they're gonna make their job
philanthropy and you can't make nests on
Java from philanthropy yeah like Leeanne
Locken is trying yeah and failing but no
one's trying harder than her ya know so
the financial I thought that was a very
intentional word and I would love to
know more about it you know like is
Megan gonna you know pick up ships like
what is she gonna do well I think it
would be easy for her to go back to
being an actress and now she could
really get those like a list role I just
don't think you could be a princess and
an actress because we that's never
happened before it would be
unprecedented but about Kelly everything
about this is I'm president that's true
but I don't think in terms she was like
that close to the ROI I don't know her
like position in the royal family I just
don't think it was as close to the king
and queen as yeah I don't know I would
love to see her become an actress again
oh my god see and then Chinese lady back
on the hallmark I would love it you know
she would be an Oscar
early films like she would then be going
to the Golden Globes with Harry like it
would be crazy I'm ready for it honestly
it wouldn't be weird do you see Pierce
Morgan it's like under fire for what he
said What did he say that she was bad
for the family well like at first she
was like you know messing up her family
with her dad and her stepsister now
she's pulling Harry away from his family
people are coming for him like he he is
also like a weird thing with Megan Marko
do you remember when he wrote that thing
or that he was like in love with her
yeah he like met her before she was a
royal she was just like an actress and
he like
claims he saw something in her like
suits and he and he wanted to meet her
and they went to a pub and they had a
great time and then she had to go meet
friends for a dinner and it would turn
out she's being set up with Harry Ian I
never spoke to her again but he only had
wonderful things to say about her and he
was so excited that she was becoming
part of the royal family because he
thought she was a nice good girl yes
so for him drugged turned yeah no it's
like he's jealous he loves her so much
she's yeah but for every Piers Morgan
like there's Melanie Bromley who thinks
that this is great for Harry I'm so glad
you said that because enews hosted the
Pierce Morgan quote which I'll give you
a hundred percent I didn't read the
Pierce Morgan article but are you saying
just the thesis is that she is no it's a
quote he tweeted it oh he said oh my god
they post so many times today people say
I'm too critical of Megan Marco but she
ditched her family ditched her dad
ditched most of her old friends split
harry from william and now has split him
from the royal family I rest my case
and literally Melanie Bromley is like in
the comments responding to everyone like
giving her opinion on because she's
British she somehow has some authority
on the royal family like if you watch
the crown you have authority on the
royal family yeah Oh a hundred percent
it's a crazy story oh and did you see
the cover of the New York Post no Meg's
it oh I saw the people are going to
Meg's it that's amazing a cartoon of
like two like trailer-trash people one
has Megan's face one says Harry's face
he's wearing underwear drinking beer on
a couch she has like hot curlers in it's
like they're joining the carpenters
that's so funny
Meg's it is so great also so I love a
good play on someone called Piers Morgan
parse Morgan's a shell here on out be
referred to as Morgan you guys this is
so crazy but what's frustrating is like
it feels like anytime there's news
surrounding the royal family like
William is saying this and Prince
Charles is saying this is like you
can't trust anything aside from the
statements that MIT they make so I don't
know where to go from here like I don't
know if there'll be new news tomorrow no
but what's cool about this is that
anytime there's a story about the Royals
it's just conjecture it's just people
like Melanie Bromley saying their
sources in the palace but now it's like
straight from the palaces mouth we got
two statements yesterday and that's why
this story is turning into such a bigger
deal than anything else because at first
for the last year it's just been rumors
source back friend says truly yesterday
and page six there was an article that
was like friend says that Megan and
Harry might leave the royal family and I
was I thought about covering it on the
show and I was like what friend
no and it's just like these friends it's
just like Melanie Bromley's cousins and
it's just not real I can't
okay well we'll keep you posted on what
happens and what jobs they get you know
I'm most concerned in this scenario
financially like the financial
independence that they made a point to
make a point of but I think financial
independence you think Harry has like a
trust it's like when your royal do you
even have a bank account I don't know
but it's like he's about to get a
reality check because it's like yeah he
knows he has probably us to pay his
taxes and pays bills but like do you
know you have to pay for water yeah no
and do you know like any dollar you make
like fifty percent of that goes to the
government especially I think in Toronto
they have even higher taxes in America
yeah I feel like he's gonna be in for a
rude awakening
yeah common her life not so common Harry
you know I want to you know why don't
you skip on over back to the royal
palace and I feel like a lot of the
reason behind their decision is because
the press has just been brutal on them
especially in the UK but I don't think
this is good they're still just as
fascinating as ever if not more
fascinating I think they could have done
this I don't know if like legally or
whatever they have to announce that they
were leaving I think they could have
quietly just like moved and like started
because like I said they're irrelevant
so like nobody really cares if they show
up to you know what I mean so I think
they could have done this in a quieter
way it's almost like they could have
avoided all of this maybe I guess like
legally like me like you have to
announce I feel like it's like when King
David and while Simpson renounce the
title and they moved to France they did
become pretty irrelevant so I guess if
they moved to Toronto I think they could
be low-key yeah if they move to New York
I don't think that they could be do you
think they're going to live in an
apartment or in a house I think they'd
have to live in an apartment yeah I
would love to see them like a studio oh
my god yeah
loft crazy times okay this next story is
also pretty crazy Mac Miller's
posthumous album circles is dropping
next week Mac Miller's family announced
that the late rappers posthumous album
titled circles will be released on
January 17th they put out a statement on
his Instagram saying here we are the act
of having to write this at all feels
surreal at the time of his passing
Malcolm was well into the process of
recording his companion album two
swimming entitled circles his family
wrote on his Instagram two different
styles complementing each other
completing a circle swimming in circles
was the concept of human they were
supposed to be their package deal right
and he had been working really hard with
this producer John Bryan on the second
album after Malcolm's passing John
dedicated himself to finishing circles
based on his time and conversations with
Malcolm we are eternally grateful to
John and to those who did their best to
the difficult and emotional task of
putting out this body of work I wonder
if they have all the songs recorded like
they have all the vocals I'm sure that
they do and anything that wasn't done
I'm sure the producer finesse right um
that's so crazy you're getting enough
those albums are so bored sorry
this is exciting for Mac Miller fans
yeah and I'm happy for him considering
it was a concept that was meant to be
together I think I think it's a nice way
to tie it all together yeah but just for
some reason like anything any news or
like story about Mac mail just like
gives me chills like it's just like I'm
obviously like happy great day album
whatever but it's just like spooky it's
spooky and I just can't help but think
of re you know right right right like
are there songs on there about her yeah
he loved to write songs about Ariana
yeah and she loves write songs about
literally anything and I think that they
were OTP by the way I've been saying OTP
a lot which makes me feel young and cool
and it means one true pair so it's like
when two people are meant to be their
endgame they're you know it's gonna be
together forever it's OTP um who did you
think was Bree van de Kamp's OTP she had
many lovers she had say something so
controversial pharmacist oh she said
Orson she had Karl Karl yeah um I was
about to say something so crazy but I do
think
it's Orson I think it was Karl but
that's what I was gonna say at first but
you know what I think it was they never
they had like the two-week like it was
hot it was a short relationship they
never got to the part where he leaves
his dirty underwear on the floor and she
has to pick it up and yell at him but
she loves picking up underwear like
that's her thing that's true and also
like we never got to the part where you
know he goes with his wandering eye and
disrespects real life right it all was
hot unfortunately Orson had run someone
over with his car but if that and then
right after that he decided to be like a
good man worthy of Bree van de Kamp's
love and if that hadn't happened like he
was it for her know if you really need
to choose he's in a pod yes in the
beginning but if you look at the end of
their relationship like through um like
a wider lens you would see that he was
like incredibly emotionally abusive and
like also held her emotionally hostage
remember once he was disabled and he
knew that she had an affair on him and
that like he knew that he could trap her
yeah but like he [ __ ] ran over Mike
no I know but like there's three
different Orson Hodges hold it Orson
that runs people over the Orson that is
OTP for Bree and the Orson that's a
schedule chair and that and whose wife
cheated on him and he just wants her
revenge
I just wouldn't breathe like had her
kitchen and then was like you know being
a businesswoman that was my favor Bree
of course and I should literally talk
about Desperate Housewives all day I
know and then she like turns into Oprah
and I'm so happy where her journey took
her it turns out OTP for Bree was just
muffins right right what's her cookbooks
right exactly it was her career it was
the kitchen it was the kitchen um being
a kitchen is Kim Kardashian's
refrigerator no it's not because we
actually have real stories today okay
can we quickly talk about how she
referred to it as a frigerator like six
times what's wrong with that
it's a fridge a refrigerator it's not a
frigerator okay well she said it more
than once it really bothered me but what
I thought to be most fast you think I
could they have a whole other kitchen
where all their meals are prepared they
have a commercial kitchen like you could
run a restaurant out of that fridge and
those ovens and that Island
crazy crazy and she's plant-based now
that food looked disgusting what a waste
of a good kitchen the food looks really
good I would love to have a commercial
kitchen and the chef that could just
make me like plant-based meals that are
low-calorie like oh my god you always
think like if I had money I would get a
big yacht or something but you never
think like how would my meals be
prepared I would get a chef who makes me
plant-based meals that are low-calorie
in a commercial kitchen because then
they could still eat like have a normal
family like snacks in the pantry like
you saw there other fridge but then it's
like behind the scenes behind a big
brown door he's like a full restaurant
staff it's crazy I was shocked by that
and like those kids when they have to
become financially independent oh good
good for them and they go to their loft
and like there's not a commercial
kitchen so sad that's gonna be a reality
shock truly um but I loved that she gave
us that tour sickening I could have used
like literally three hours more of
stories oh and something else it's not a
story today but speaking of news that's
sickening and I refuse to report I'm in
a real capacity because I refused to
believe it is that Jeffrey starring me
like are kaput
okay so here's my theory and so many
people are reporting it enews like it's
real news and the only proof that we
haven't said he canceled his makeup tour
with momma Mitchell in the UK means
nothing and that he took wife of Nate
out of his bio so they released a video
like literally three days before all
these people said that they were
breaking up and they were totally fine
Nate has recently decided to be
completely off social media and I think
part of that is like literally his name
not even being in Geoffrey's bio like I
didn't think that was crazy
but my theory is very sadly and I hope
is not true I said I believe Jeffrey's
mother died he had said in his most
recent video that obviously him an 8 or
the aren't only people living in this
house they've a lot of family moving in
his mom he doesn't know how much time
they have left together which made me
think she might have been sick so I do
think that um sadly his mother died
that's also really sad also they just
like I don't know what it could be but
jeopardy Nate just put out a video
together and like they've been together
for so long that even if they were gonna
break up it wouldn't happen in a week no
it's also it's just it's not true like
everyone's it's really [ __ ] annoying
like everyone reporting on it like it's
true Dancing pictures of them on
Instagram with I got a broken heart it's
not true they're fine well we don't know
that for certain but I'm gonna I just
have my gut is telling me they're
they're fine in it something else
they have such a good struggle like they
might as well be married like they're
they're fine I know it okay did you have
something else that you wanted to say I
did because I was talking on Kim
Kardashian and like her kitchen like can
you just imagine like living in a house
like that like opening up a bottle of
wine and just like being Kim Kardashian
like looking out on your own your vistas
and your commercial kitchen no I can't
but for the rest of us there's
hellofresh
there is
yes since week since we can't have a
chef
I love hella fresh when my mom doesn't
have time to make dinner from scratch
she makes hella fresh I can't even tell
the difference every time we do ad we
get a little window into how sad
American campers life is her mom is a
deadbeat drunk but she lives with her
grandma Gracie and her grandma makes her
hellofresh you can get mouth-watering
seasonal recipes and pre measured
ingredients delivered right to your door
with hellofresh
America's number one meal kit hellofresh
makes cooking at home fun easy and
affordable their recipes are so
delicious you could save time and stress
it's very effortless they can help you
eat more sustainably there pre-portioned
ingredients mean there's less prep for
you and less food waste the packaging
hellofresh uses to ship your food is
mostly is almost entirely made from
recyclable and/or recycled content their
carbon footprint is 25 percent lower
than store-bought grocery mate meals you
can add extra meals or lunches to your
weekly order are throwing yummy sides
and desserts like garlic bread for the
Italian camber and cookie dough for the
American camper you can break out of
your dinner rot they have 22 more than
22 seasonal chef's carry the recipes
each week there's something for everyone
including low-calorie vegetarian which
is what we got and family friendly
recipes so I can feed theum check it out
we think you guys will really like it
it's now from five dollars and 66 cents
per serving which is really interesting
too statistic it is America's number one
meal kit the best value meal kit and we
think you guys will really enjoy it so
you should definitely check it out and
obviously we have an offer for you guys
go to hello fresh com /
toast 10 and use the code toast 10
that's toas t10 during hello freshers
new year sale for 10 free meals
including free shipping so again make
sure you go to hello fresh com / toast
10 and use the code toast tendering
hello freshers new year sale for 10 free
meals and free shipping check it out we
think you guys really enjoy it it's
funny easy and a great way to start off
your new year if your resolution is to
cook more is to save on ordering in or
just you know get healthy yeah I
actually have my hello fresh delivery
coming next week and I'm so excited it's
the perfect thing for the new year like
do you think oh do you want to come over
at can make you holla fries
I really really love hellofresh like
it's a game-changer
I don't you yeah it's great for like
people like me it's great for families
it's great for grandmas providing for
their campers right okay
next story another crazy bit of news
Grimes is pregnant Oh Elon Musk's
girlfriend shares what page six is
calling a bizarre baby bump photo but I
think it's quite artistic it's very
Grimes
it's so Grimes look if I put this out I
would make no goddamn sense and my
titties would be like way lower to the
ground I wouldn't be able to see the
bump but um I guess she's pregnant
because it looks like there's like a
fetus reflecting off of her belly in the
nude photo and then people were
commenting because her nipples are
showing I'm not sure if the photos still
up but she responded to a commenter
saying I thought about censoring them
her nipples for a hot minute but the
photo is so much less funeral without
the nipples plus being knocked up is
Fura land warlike state of being
might as well be what it is okay Grimes
so you're pregnant I we have to assume
that it is I mean I I'm pretty sure
she's pregnant but it could also just be
like an artistic photo no it's
definitely pregnant like she literally
like hot put a holographic baby in her
belly this is a pregnancy announcement I
think we're supposed to believe that her
and Ilana are still together because we
saw a picture of them at the Kardashian
Christmas party I just can't believe
that they're still together because
during that like crazy time real on mass
was like on a downward spiral accusing
the the Thai rescuer of being a
pedophile like that was a crazy time and
he like started to take crimes it looks
like he was spinning out of control like
dating this crazy girl but like no
they're they seem to be very much in
love and like live together and now
we're having a baby
no totally and then he he that case went
through and Ilan like wasn't charged
with different animation and also I read
a story today I'm gonna share with the
class that Tesla is now the most
valuable US auto company in history
worth more than GM and Ford so I think
he's doing okay I like lo he wanted
Tesla like not that I want that I want
the one that everyone was making fun of
no I really want um just more regular
one worth more than GM and Ford combined
Wow that's crazy and that's so crazy
because then you would think it would be
so popular like maybe it's just in New
York like I never see Tesla's no um
maybe it is just in New York because I
know everyone in LA
has one yeah shares of the electric
carmaker have been surging in the market
cap of the company has broken the 80
billion dollar auto valuation record set
by Ford in 1999 Ford and GM still far
outpaced Tesla in terms of car sales but
investors are betting that Tesla's
growth makes it worth more long term I
think Elon is on his path yeah I I
really been like wanting a Tesla just
like seeing how cool it is like on
Instagram and stuff which is incredibly
losery of me but then I saw a video once
I think it was Colt in like you like was
almost out of electricity or whatever
you fill your car up with and he like
pulled over in LA to go to one of those
like electricity gas stations and the
line was like so crazy because everyone
in LA has a Tesla like what if you just
get [ __ ] like can you get yeah like
you have a Mophie charger for your phone
and you'd like a Mophie fur tester Elon
is working ot yeah he's working on it
yeah and I want to get a Tesla except
that I can't drive but soon they'll be
self trying actually I saw a
self-driving Tesla
yeah Jeffery started a YouTube video on
the 405 freeway self-driving and did his
makeup that's crazy
he said please don't try this at home
that's so crazy I'm so happy for Ilan
and Grimes like it's not the
relationship that I would have imagined
yeah but it's the one that seems to be
working and it seems like they're both
you know very spiritual artistic free
spirit I'll say so I actually think Loki
this is a great match yeah it's working
and like his company is business is
booming I'm sorry I like totally I
cannot believe we've been talking about
namaz for this long and I always you
know when like cool things happen to you
and you like forget about them like I
met Elon Musk and he said he loved my
blog that's crazy
no that was crazy that's really nice of
him to say considering you like don't
really have a blog okay but it made me
feel like he meant your Instagram I
think it meant just like my digital
footprint doesn't he followed Ben yes
but I don't know her so he has familiar
with the nose job like a crazy Instagram
like downward spiral he might have
unfollowed bench and I check yeah please
please I just forget we talked about
Elon Musk like this figure but it's like
I'm actually oh my basket I'm actually a
close personal friend of Elon Musk
mm-hmm let me check he definitely
doesn't follow me but for a brief period
of time he did follow Ben Elon Musk oh
he's off Instagram oh okay interesante
that's good for him well I'm really
happy for the two of them
I just love to see a successful
relationship in Hollywood and in Silicon
Valley or whatever are you ready for our
next story because it's actually a
little bit of life imitates art news
into her son you're gonna have to be
careful of those baskets I know I just
knocked one over I'm so sorry I'm not
used to my new workspace Leonardo
DiCaprio rescues a man who fell off a
yacht in your st. Barths what the
internet he's always on a yacht no and
good thing like he was trained for this
in the film Titanic which I just watched
the other night and it's so beautiful
Leonardo DiCaprio sprang into action to
save a man who had fallen off a Club Med
yacht near Saint Martin on December 30th
I was Leonardo DiCaprio doing at a club
Med No
someone else fell off the Club Med yacht
and then Leo's yacht rolled through and
saved this man who had been treading
water for 11 hours
Leo's boat was the only vessel looking
for him what Leo on the boat he was on
okay man falls off Club Med yacht yeah
I'm having like 11 hours later Leo's got
fine Tim Leo pulls him up some sexy hose
yacht with Leo on it yes okay Leo and
his girlfriend they make sure to mention
that she's 22
kamilla mirage yep the couple and some
friends subtly heard a distress call for
a man in need of help the actor insisted
on braving the rough waters to find the
man one hour before sunset and with a
storm approaching
luckily DiCaprio's boat eventually
located the man who was frantically
waving his hands in the air
the castaway had been treading water for
11 hours that's crazy and what men like
I can get your [ __ ] together you know we
can't talk about Leo and we can't talk
about a yacht without me mentioning at
least once that I was on a lot a yacht
with Leo and this is oddly reminiscent
because when you get on a yacht I don't
know if everyone knows this I'm you have
to take like a little boat to the yacht
you'd most of the time and we took this
in they call it a dinghy and we took
this dinghy and we got on the yacht and
then we got off the yacht and back on
the day they take us back to shore we
got caught in the middle of a storm and
it was one of the fact she thought I was
gonna die like with Leonardo DiCaprio
and I really wasn't upset because like I
would have been included like in like
the list of oh but it would have been
like Leo and six others you know yeah it
would have been like Leo and fellow
stars because okay they were on the boat
not stars and maybe just maybe my name
it would have been like Leonardo
DiCaprio girlfriend 22
Ansel Elgort and mistress 25
Hylton an unidentifiable brunette and it
was really crazy so honestly I I know
that Leo is a man he's a noble man and a
nautical man and this is not a
surprising story as seeing as how like I
said I have been on a yacht with Leo and
the man was a severely dehydrated Club
Med worker who had too much alcohol oh
wait he was he worked for club man yeah
and he was drinking on the job and like
jumping off I guess I don't know
interesante they're integers on what is
Club Med it's like a chain of hotels
where people like swing he's like Canyon
is it Canyon Ranch no it's not secret
it's like it's a honestly it's a
combination of candy and ranch and
secrets it's just like a popular hotel
chain they have a lot of like kids clubs
it's like I don't know I've never been
but I do know when we were when I was
like in middle school this girl in our
friend group went to a Club Med and like
a literary meta boy and like had a
million friends and she was like on
vacation like with and she made a group
of friends on the vacation thing and I
thought it was so B I will never relate
to kids who talk to other kids on
vacation but they said that's like a
Club Med thing I guess I'm not going to
come at like that was always so crazy
when people came back from winter break
and we were like in eighth grade they're
like I met someone like my brother I've
literally never met someone on vacation
except at one time and no like once
you're in college fine like when you're
in high school and like your vacation
like well you're on a cruise and there's
like other I'm sorry I think that and
then you're like I am I your cruise
friends and Jaggi at any age it's
incredibly weird
me and Ben one time you're like an adult
and you go no I disagree what's me and
Ben one time made a couple for me no but
this story like the two of you were in a
casino and like you made a friend of the
night but like oh you don't know you're
wrong you couldn't meet someone on
vacation like if you're both staying at
like a nice hotel and you meet at the
bar like that's look ok listen
me and Ben went on vacation we used to
go to Puerto Rico like once a year and
we would literally spend every single
night at the casino and this one trip we
were staying at the ritz-carlton in San
Juan great hotel and the first night we
like met two couples and they were like
so fun they were like from New Jersey be
like both really liked each other and we
were like let's meet again the next
night you know and we did and it was
like a four nights in a row to the other
couples hung out during the day but me
and Brad like couldn't like we we
already thought it was too weird and
then
the last night it was all too good to be
true because they were like this like
shady couple from I want to say New
Jersey and they said some really
anti-semitic remarks to us and that was
the last time we ever saw them so that's
why that's why you shouldn't make
friends on vacation I don't know if
that's why you shouldn't
and also like meeting people at the
blackjack table is different then you
know if you're a single person looking
for another single person you can meet
people all the time but I'm sorry that
that happened to you sis
sorry th EO was being a B ad bo y we got
it you guys whose anything just like his
mother a plastic tag he's just a hungry
boy okay are you ready for a fifth and
final story because we need to recap
rabbit last night am I ready for the
final story because we need to recap
robber from last night yes julianne
hough and Brooks Laich are quote
spending time apart okay you guys they
are like doing PR moves of the century
like rolling out this divorce in like a
very meticulous way first he started
with his resolutions about exploring his
sexuality
now they've announced that they're
spending time apart and then like in a
few weeks will tell you that they're
getting divorced
yes she hasn't been wearing her ring
like for the last few weeks of the
toasters called this because they've
been posting about it for the last month
so just goes to show you the toasters
know everything yeah but this was
actually I mean it's not shocking
because I saw it in toasters but like
the first time I heard that there was
you know disruption between the two of
them it was shocking because like I
shipped these two so hard they had the
most beautiful wedding on a boat on a
lake showing up on a boat and it just
makes me I mean I know Instagram isn't
real but like it's [ __ ] deceptive as
hell like like I would have put these in
my top five perfect couples on Instagram
like yeah that are gonna go the distance
like getting married in Idaho I feel
like she doesn't have good luck in love
she was why he seems like a great guy
like I I don't understand even knowing
that they're like on the road to divorce
like I am not understanding what went
wrong who is he he's a former hockey
player and now he has a podcast like
living the dream
honestly the whole podcast community is
mourning this yeah we really are and she
is just a star stunning it was so nice
to us maybe she's just too big of a star
she was so nice to us when we went her
and I told her I was such a big fan and
she really was so appreciative she said
she liked your hair color yeah she was
like trying to be redhead yes she
thought I was cute
like Jackie wasn't gonna say hi and I
pulled you Leon happen and said my
sister's not gonna say I think I got a
picture with her she loves you like she
thinks you're just a star and she
literally wasn't weirded out at all she
was so [ __ ] nice and I have the
utmost respect for a respectful queen
yeah um I think I got a picture with her
I need to find it like she's the board
Music Awards was a great day yeah was it
no um but back to the two of them this
is I just don't understand how to like
they seem perfect like what's the
problem here I know it's just I just
like Channing Tatum and Jessie J we
never talked about the fact they broke
up and I stay there that's devastating
because it was such a weird pairing and
then they like stayed together for a
long time and you're like oh they were
so supportive of each other's endeavors
this is the end for them like he was
always watching her sing Domino like she
this Jessie J is like funny to me I
don't know why I love her ever since she
had a broken leg at the VMAs and had a
bedazzled like house and sat on a chair
while singing like I've had the utmost
respect for her and nobody respects her
career-wise no it's so strange but I
respect her career eyes any time she
comes out with a new song like I'm
listening but she's gonna be my top
artist of this she's she's a part of one
of the best songs ever made which is
bang bang she's also on Domino such a
good song flashlight like she really
kills it um brave brave yes she's just a
great artist who's underappreciated much
like Rascal Flatts and look what happens
when you don't appreciate your talent
they break up yeah maybe every lay maybe
wait I think it's supported Jessie J
Moore her and Channing Tatum would still
be together it's you know what kids
always play them blame themselves yeah
it's our fault
it is I'm really excited to recap all
the shows that were on last night
because it was a great night to be a
Bravo fan like I just and even Ben who
doesn't really like watching he got in
bed because he was so tired and he was
just watching with me and he was loving
and he felt really bad for Carrie
Brittingham yes um should we start with
Dallas then no but let's go an order of
how it aired which is New Jersey okay
because I watched last week's New Jersey
and this week so I want to talk about
both though mostly just what happened at
this store but it was so like it was
such a great night I'm sure you popped
open a bottle of wine I did I popped
open a bottle of wine which is just a
new thing that I'm doing ever since I
started subscribing to first leave
saving money on award-winning wine
you're guaranteed to love has never been
easier than it is with first leaf unlike
other wine clubs that guess about your
favorite wines first leaf uses your
feedback and ratings to curate wine
selections personalized to your unique
tastes first leaf is so confident in the
quality of their wine
that they even have a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed that means if
you're not feeling like like feeling a
particular bottle of wine first sleep
will cover it completely we got started
by taking the first leaf twine quiz to
assess our exact wine drinking
preferences the best part about the quiz
is that it's not intimidating they don't
use fancy sommelier words it's like what
do you like red or yellow it's just it's
really it's it's in layman's terms from
sweetness to wine styles to even how
adventurous we are they learned all
about what we like first leaf then
created an introductory six pack of wine
for me all for just $29.95 seriously
six packs six bottles of wine for under
$30 these wines will normally go for
twenty dollars a bottle and then when my
bottles arrived we tasted them we rated
them online they took our ratings and
select and unique wine wine styles based
on our taste for our next shipment in
fact first leaf sends out more than
17,000 unique shipments of wine every
month because everyone's tastes are so
different try first leave wine club
today we're buying great wine is simple
sign up with our link and you'll get an
exclusive intro offer six bottles of
wine for just $29.95 plus free shipping
go to try first leaf dot-com slash toast
that's six bottles of wine for only
$29.95 plus free shipping at try first
leaf dot-com slash toast t ry first le
AF dot-com slash T la st sign on and get
your buzz on sign on get drunk at home
in the comfort of your home own home
with no judgment okay Real Housewives of
New Jersey we got the follow-up to the
hair-pulling we saw the whole saga
Margaret was really choked up yeah I
want to talk about the hair-pulling from
top to bottom I want to talk about the
whole thing because I know everyone's
saying like if you poured water on me
what do you expect me to do but like
Danielle got in Margaret's face first
she made it physical first by getting in
her face literally she walks up in her
face and says get out of my face yeah so
[ __ ] crazy
and Margaret honestly pouring and I
agree with Jennifer what she said in
this episode it's like pouring water on
her like it's not that huge of a deal
like it's not like it's it's alcoholic
head singer eyes like it's annoying sure
but like she's not you punched her in
the face and it's a like she pulled her
hair like if Danielle got in her face
and then Margaret threw water on her and
didn't yell left Margaret would have
been wrong because you can't throw water
on someone but in the grand scheme of a
big fight it's not a big deal no but
Danielle got in her face and Marga threw
water in her and I thought they were
even really
and then and then Danielle going through
her bag break like it was so [ __ ]
rude that that Florida City candle isn't
literally five thousand dollars like and
what's crazy and that they showed us is
that saying y'all knew how much it was
before she went and broke it yeah like
they made it over they made a point for
them they they showed them asking how
much it was like it was so disrespectful
so trashy and I'm already like biased
towards Margaret like I [ __ ] love her
and I think she's so precious and so
maybe if she was wrong I would even
still be on her side but she was just
like so right and it was it was so it
was so trashy and beastly beastly and
Margaret called her a beast and I was
like yes Queen I felt so bad for
Margaret because honestly someone
pulling your ponytail and you have to
bend it backwards so much especially for
an older woman like I did not think she
was being dramatic the next day with the
ice on not at all I really felt bad for
and she was so choked up and I think she
was in physical pain but she was more so
like in shock being attacked it's like
shocking yeah I felt so bad for her I
felt so bad for her Theresa is
completely wrong completely out of
control
if I were Margaret I wouldn't have even
given Theresa that ultimatum to give her
a chance to choose me I would have said
I am never speaking to you ever again
and you know what like I liked Theresa
as a person when she comes on the show
she's always so nice but like I'm able
to separate people on the show from the
people when we meet them and like I am
absolutely done with her as a cast
member on Real Housewives of New Jersey
the entitlement the way that she behaves
that she thinks she can get away with it
and like her behavior in these two
episodes was so abhorrent that it made
like she no longer gets that past that
her husband's a nice I agree and then
her kids are going through it like she
found a way to even supersede that
brunch and on watch repens ID last night
to nail stab announced that she will
never return to Real Housewives me
asking you but I do think that'll make a
an interesting conversation for next
season because a lot of the women are
now turned on Theresa and she doesn't
have that now Danielle's not there so
she's gonna have to try and at least
make amends with everyone but she
doesn't know how and I can't believe she
doesn't listen to Dolores cuz Dolores is
show up her ass but even Dolores now is
like you're out of control
yeah and Jennifer like everyone
confronting Teresa and saying like
you're wrong it made me really happy
because I know a lot of them are afraid
of her and like she is like the head
honcho of the show and if you don't get
along with Teresa you're probably not
gonna last long and I really appreciated
everyone in the store
saying like Teresa you are so wrong then
even at the the NV Fashion Show Jennifer
speaking to her and I can't believe
Jennifer didn't freak out more like that
was and then Trudy said throwing a glass
behind the bar like she's an animal like
I she completely lost me like you know
actually so mad at her just as mad as I
am at Danielle say I think they're
equally response and I pray that
Margaret does not forgive forgive or
even Teresa is not apologizing right so
I hope that Margit doesn't initiate
conversation with her like if I were
Margaret I would just be like okay I see
who you are I'm never speaking to you
again know that and I think Margaret is
a strong enough woman in a strong enough
cast member that she doesn't need to
lick Teresa's [ __ ] I agree and you
want to know why because she also has
Melissa on her side and Melissa is just
as much an important character honestly
as Teresa is they're like the - I would
say mainstays in the cast and her and
Margaret are ride-or-die for each other
so I think Margaret is safe I think and
honestly it's just [ __ ] like Teresa
has not been a good friend to Margaret
for a while but now Margaret has a real
reason to never be Teresa's friend again
yeah it's like Teresa just doesn't like
Margaret and yeah and her lat and by the
way the things I think I was saying in
the store before the women got they're
like talking [ __ ] about Margaret and her
looks and and called her chunky the heel
sing like and Teresa laughing also like
Danielle's for like pushing all this
alcohol and Teresa do you know decide
the champagne yeah oh my god she had
like four champagnes before people got
there and treats and Daniella is just
keeps feeding her alcoholic wants to get
her drunk and I don't know what the mo
is there but it's creepy
the friendship between Teresa and
Danielle is so strange and it really
reminds me of the friendship between
Cameron and Leanne like it makes no
goddamn sense and everyone would be
better off
he doesn't remind me of the friendship
because like I I can maybe even
understand Cameron and Leanne and
Cameron calls out land and then Cameron
turns on Leanne but she also is a friend
and wants to be sympathetic towards
Leanne but like Teresa is just like
she's blind like she's a blind judge
like I don't even know it's the weirdest
friendship I felt so so bad for Margaret
like I just I love her so much
we got one minute a bill Aden and I just
was like smiling the whole time him
getting dressed like your life is so
hard with all your different pairs of
shoes and then we got a preview for the
next couple of episodes where he gets
like wasted and they have to carry him
home love it I love bill Aden and I love
the Ayden's and I'm
seeing their family their family dynamic
and when they were having Easter I was
like but they showed us Easter for
everyone else last week they have
different I know and I'm loving learning
about the traditions and I love her kids
and I just I'm really I'm so here for
Jennifer I was so happy to see she's on
the right side it did I know she
inherently like doesn't get along with
Margaret and those girls and she just
was drawn more to Teresa in the
beginning when she first got on the show
just like jackie was more drawn to
Morgan and Teresa I mean Margaret and
Melissa um Frankie Tonia walking in the
show like there girls growing wild that
was so [ __ ] huge he is in love with
him and like so are we so it's totally
fine
he lives took cute I thought Melissa
really pulled off a great fashion show I
thought she did - I'm so like I liked
the fashion meet you know the history of
the housewives we have had some sad
[ __ ] fashion shows and I thought this
was one that was just really premium I
completely agree also
[ __ ] what did I want - there's so much
more I wanted to talk about fashion show
Frank Catania melissa getting on stage
and just being like I love being a woman
I love being a business you know I don't
think the fashion show I think it was
about doing oh when they were all
fighting before the water was fell down
like Margaret was spitting straight
facts about Marty and the situation and
like Artie is such an idiot
such an idiot I'm done with you Marty I
hope Margaret's done with you too but
like I understand Margaret's like a
bigger person than I am and doesn't just
cut people out of her life so she should
she should in that moment she should
have literally never spoken to Marty
again Marty is the reason for all of
this by the way yeah so when she was
hanging either either you made up lies
about Marty abusing you and your
daughters or he abused you and your
daughters and you're still living with
him yeah I don't know what's happened to
the Duke of Sussex Oliver Oh buddy hey
what happened I whatever to that woman
with the boutique who was dating him
first she like came and went one it was
like she always asked me and Dutchess
and then and she was engaged right what
happened
okay oh and Daniel I'll be on watch -
happens like I'm sorry I'm just like so
fed up with her I was you don't
disrespect Margaret like back in the day
flipping tables it was all funny like
they're all like you know just being
dramatic for level but like it was so
abusive also um why did she get that
chair
Stephanie Holman is a real housewife
she's so in the second chair oh I don't
know but you know what I don't see
Stephanie a 70 Homan just looks like
she was just gonna I'm sorry mind your
P's and Q's I cannot believe that we
have set here for so long we didn't even
talk about the fact that we were on TMZ
yesterday oh my gosh Wow our new set
made it to TMZ I told you guys I got TMZ
with Jackson Britney and literally I've
been TMZ like three times in my life and
nobody has ever put it anywhere because
I guess I'm like not that famous but
they put it on TMZ TV yesterday they
were like making fun of me because I
gave bad answers I was like so drunk and
I just like didn't have good answers to
their questions but they were making fun
of me and I literally don't care because
like that's the first bit of good press
I've literally ever gotten so thank you
so much team Z Harvey I see you I love
you and I appreciate you and I will come
back any time I live if you want to wait
outside my building love to see it I'm
so excited for the new set that it was
on TMZ thank you it's having such a
great week and they called us a Morning
Show podcast love it that's what we are
do you I love people who do their
research yes love okay any other
thoughts on Jersey before we officially
close this book um just say I was truly
horrified I had like a a pit in my
stomach Margaret is a precious gem of a
woman who protected at all costs and I'm
I'm really out on obviously doing Alba
Teresa to like I don't know I don't I
don't know how she can come back from
this for me I was just like liking her
uh it's the thing is with Teresa like
I've always liked her but I've never
agreed with her but something some
switch flipped last night where I just
stopped being sympathetic to her cause
completely because she's so unreasonable
and she literally so hypocritical and
makes is so illogical she was talking to
Dolores about like saying like Margaret
felt like you should have had her back
and in Teresa being like she's a grown
woman I don't need to have her back
meanwhile she's sitting out I'll have
your back
Yeah right and Danielle's like you're
gonna have my back right I need you to
have my back but you're a grown woman as
well I started to like Jackie a little
bit better last night's episode cuz she
was on the right side of history and she
made she made a good point she was like
you're gonna you're waiting for Teresa
to come up to you that's literally never
gonna happen Margaret and then she also
said something important Oh old-school
Italian doesn't mean she's like when
Dolores close someone old-school it just
means that they're gonna attack you or
somebody like it was just a really
poignant point yeah they were like
saying that Teresa's old-school Italian
which is why she doesn't isn't like
that's not no no okay I really want to
talk about Alice because that's
obviously the me and potatoes here part
two of the reunion and final which is
shocking me at three of OC but two of
dollies Jackie I
was thinking the same thing but there's
a position isn't discuss he doesn't
compress it they drag it out all the
texture that Jerry reunion could be one
part but no they drag it out to three I
thought it was really surprising and
kind of a letdown that we only got two
because I could have spoken about the
racism thing for one jalapeno and also
yeah and this episode was really eerie
because it was just like clouding over
everything every discussion like you're
talking about Thailand they're talking
about the dress and it's wait none of
that matters anymore yeah you know we're
all just needing to talk about the baby
elephant in the room
Andy it's just like on the N he is a lie
detector like any time it's hot he also
keeps saying thing about things about
production like production wouldn't let
us talk to her she's singing about
things about production that would
excuse her behavior completely and Andy
who is a producer knows that that's not
true right like even with the food as a
wedding like the crew needs to eat like
the wedding was all the time by the way
I do think Andy should overall always be
completely neutral but every now and
then he does like kind of take a side
and I love it because that means he
feels like really passionately about it
like when everyone was coming for
Bethenny like he was the only one to
fattening her like three seasons ago and
he's the only person I calling out
LeeAnn on her [ __ ] and he's the only
person who really can debunk what she's
saying when it comes to production so it
has a lot of like levity to it you know
yeah also um I could have gotten a third
part because the women looked so
beautiful I wasn't done looking at them
oh I wasn't done looking at D'Andra
shoulder I just wasn't oh her shoulder
look great
I had to literally stop and pause the
reunion and show Ben because like
watching Brandi he'd be like so high on
her horse saying all this stuff to LeAnn
when we now know in real time that video
that resurfaced have resurfaced of her
doing an Asian accent which I've
actually been talking to to Aarthi Wayne
about because she was like really really
upset I didn't she posted on her
Instagram and she tagged Brandi and
Brandi actually DM her back and they
like had a conversation and Jonathan did
a really good job of explaining I mean
anyone should know why it's offensive
but I explaining like from an Asian
person like why it's so horrible when
did she say she was just like making
jokes like that like obviously it's a
joke but it makes other stereotypes like
and it makes other people comfortable to
say even worse things because it's just
like a stepping stone from calling
someone you know something even worse
yeah and so watching her be like so high
and mighty with his chair and like
pretend to cry
like that was just honestly it was a lot
I don't think she was pretending to go
out on the transport I think she really
had a visceral reaction when she and she
was really one of the few people who
didn't experience it firsthand so she
you know was able to see it like the
rest of us did and like be really
discussing and she's sitting next to
this person and her family they're out
of it but of course nobody's perfect
I've got just the timing of all of it so
bad it was so bad it makes her look like
such a hypocrite
part of the reason why what Leon said is
so bad is also because like she's not
implicating other people like now kind
of Stephanie and Cameron look kind of
shitty for not saying something sooner
because it was such a horrible thing to
say and it's like they're now in trouble
and having to apologize to carry weight
at the end of the day they didn't do
anything you know what I mean it's like
what she did is so bad and she's also
bringing other people down which is
making it worse
ya know but what was really interesting
was Andy calling all out all the women
but also kind of calling they wound up
calling him out because he was like you
guys never thought this was gonna air
and so they made them look like they
would have never told Carrie if it
wasn't gonna air but it also showed that
like Leon has probably said it as a
horse things that did an error and so if
the girls had had come to someone with
it it wouldn't like it's just there's
all this dirty blonde it I want to know
and stephanie was saying on watch what
happens I'd like production is
productively in before like she's done
some really terrible things like I would
like to know what those things are I'm
very curious because it's like what were
you protecting what did she do right and
if this made it what didn't cuz this is
bad right interesting I felt so bad for
Carrie Brittingham like oh my god oh my
god talking about this for so long but
we actually haven't even heard from her
and to have to like fight with other
women about catty [ __ ] like that's
just honestly what being a real
housewife is but you don't expect to
have to come in and like defend yourself
for being a certain nationality did you
know what I mean and when she have to go
through this whole reunion when the
conversation is just like waiting at the
end of it and it's like everything else
is irrelevant now because it's like and
Carrie started to say this but she was
cut off it's like it made her feel like
LeAnn never liked her so he because she
was a Mexican yeah no no and it's like
they've been fighting all this time and
they can't get along and it's like oh
now we know why write it it was so silly
to even waste their time trying to like
argue and build a friendship or hash it
out because at the end of the day there
was always this
and it was even more frustrating cuz I
understand that like people make
mistakes and what she said was so
horrible but I think as people were
forgiving yeah and her apologies were
just so awful oh my god and she was fake
crying she's in genuine yes exactly and
she was like and Kari was saying I don't
accept because it's not real yeah and
and that's how I felt too the fake
crying no and by the way people are
totally entitled to make mistakes and
the amount of times that Leanne said it
makes me think that she didn't know that
it was offensive it was just like a dumb
thing to say um but my god like when you
get called out on something like just
own it like and she was owning it in in
an in a way where she kept making
excuses while also owning it and then
also fake crying and the fake cried was
too much for me and the awkward silence
was just too much yeah it was it was it
was not good so I'm really curious to
see how they handle that coming forward
no one said anything about her keeping
or not keeping her job I am like 100%
certain that she's getting fired I think
you like and II would have said that on
what happened sighs last night or
something maybe they're waiting to see
how people respond to it but I don't
think she helped herself at all at the
reunion I just think this is unchartered
waters for housewives and we're saying
that this is him and he's coming up on
Atlanta Oh
when Oh Kim Zolciak yeah but she's not
on Housewives anymore it she said that
racism yeah oh my god yeah yeah I don't
know if that's why but she was gone
after that okay
she said something really [ __ ] stupid
on the reunion reunion something about
how racism like is over like it was just
really stupid and she that was her last
reunion I don't know if that's the
reason but I think this is for the most
part really unchartered territory
and they have to like draw a line in the
sand like because people get crazy they
do crazy things they say crazy things
but I don't think that this is something
they really want to have be a topic of
discussion very frequently and I do
think they have to like take a stand and
I'd like Kerry Brittingham I don't want
her to leave I like her so much
but I don't know why how and why she
would ever feel comfortable like filming
with LeAnn again right and I think I
think man does have to go I'm I'm like
certain that she's gone I don't have any
proof yeah I don't see a path for both
of them to be on there and there it
would be they can't fire Karen no and
she's a great housewife great house age
is money oh sorry
and she has money and you know what I
mean she's real about her life like an
honest about her relations
work isn't what you think it no one like
her husband and their dynamic and I
think she speaks to a lot of women who
just like art I have those same concerns
but not to be an elitist or anything but
just like actually the show Real
Housewives is about an upper like elite
class of women um
and the spending the first part of the
reunion talking about how Leeanne
couldn't afford so many things at her
wedding it's just not on-brand to be
honest and I think of all the franchises
like we went through a couple seasons on
New York where literally none of the
women have money I think Dallas is one
of the most prestigious in terms of
money like the Wescott's
Stephanie is super wealthy d answer like
everyone that Brandi it really does not
make sense for LeAnn to be on the show
now more than ever like she's just not
she's friends with them but she's not a
part of society that conversation was
just so cringe a yeah oh god I want to
talk I want to get to like the Real
Housewives a part the of you know like
the drama um
I agree about LeAnn but it's also like
she is part of the community because
she's uh philanthropic and friends with
everyone but what I don't like is like
she is wearing a Birkin and she said her
friend gave it to her please she wears a
new Gucci thing and every single seen
new Chanel every bag is designer like
belt jewelry a shirt like she has the
most expensive wardrobe on the cast and
then claims that she can't pay for a
wedding and to me I don't like that sort
of inconsistency ya know that's that's a
little shot a being you know who also
it's kind of like it's so different but
that gives me that good to reach vibe to
like the house the cars but like then
they like also I have a story every day
that they have no money I don't know I
love her too I really do but she also
has some inconsistencies the most part
she puts on a good facade wait this
didn't even make it into the stories
today but speaking of Beverly Hills do
you see the drama about Denise
Richardson Brandi Glanville they had an
affair
yeah and now like Denise is no longer
filming housewives because apparently
Denise and Aaron have an open
relationship
but Brandi like told Aaron that hampern
Denise were hooking up and Aaron didn't
know I saw the title say affair and I'm
like they must be using a fare and a
different like they were hooking not oh
into her sod yeah sounds really good to
say yeah it's like we don't need Lisa
Vanderpump like no Denise and Rani are
having an affair and to be honest it's
not a fair if they have an open
relationship and I guess Denise didn't
want to share that on the show but I
would love to see the intricacies of an
open relationship while also having an
affair with
fellow housewives like that's good TV
yeah it's great she could just be open
about it like I think that would be cool
I agree okay I want to talk about the
Ameren Stephanie the country club the
elitism what are your thoughts where do
you land this is this is so hard for me
I know because Cameron is just wrong and
I like her so much in the fight with
Stephanie she's 100% wrong and this is
the exact same fight she had with Brandi
last year where it's a miscommunication
where she thought someone said she
thought everyone she said by your baby
remember and it was like a
miscommunication and they gone to a huge
fight over the fact that like they had
just misheard each other and then this
year with this surface friendship she
doesn't know what that means and she
thinks that Brandi called her dumb I
mean Stephanie called her dumb
so it's both time she's like got into
fights with people where there's been a
misunderstanding / miscommunication and
she won't she won't understand that like
she yes she can't officially she thinks
that they called her stupid when nobody
called her stupid so with the Stephanie
things and she's just keeps coming for
Stephanie and Stephanie's so nice and in
Brandi I mean in Stephanie verse Kamryn
like I'm firmly on Team Stephanie like I
think Cameron's being so petty
she was petty the whole season like I
just I thought I think she's completely
wrong and then with the LeAnn stuff I
totally understood what she was saying
when she was like I planned to confront
LeAnn attend her but then everyone went
so nuts at dinner that I'm not gonna be
a pile-on
I got that I got that [ __ ] whether she's
friends with LeAnn or not to be a
pile-on is just not nice so I totally
understood but then she just like won't
call LeAnn out even with the Carrie
Brittingham stuff like she was very
quiet and very like circling the drain
and I just I I like Cameron so much and
I've grown on her so much but she has a
lot of growing up to do and I just was
really turning on her on the last
episode like she's just she she
contradicts herself all the time like
talking about if she's not an elitist
and then like saying elitist things like
I just she is she has some work to do in
terms of me and like being a full stand
because she's wrong in the Stephanie
fight I don't know I love them both and
I really see both of their sides and I
just need them to see each other you
know because I really I feel like
Cameron is very much a part of this
society world and as much as she doesn't
like the word in the term like she
recognizes that that's the reality right
and by the way and she plays into those
types of conversations all the time so
her pretending like it doesn't exist
while also being a part of it makes no
goddamn sense so she's not pretending
like it doesn't exist she's just saying
she doesn't like she's a part of it but
she doesn't like it but she's a part of
it but
she is yes that's what she married yeah
but she doesn't pretend like it doesn't
exist but so when she doesn't pretend
and she's like no Leanne like I could
have you excommunicated that oh she's
gonna eat it yes but but if that's the
reality
I don't know did you think that those
Thailand ping-pong shows were sex
workers I didn't see the show I don't
know any I don't know yeah I mean I
guess I'm have to do an extensive amount
of research in it but I do think it's
just a part of the culture like I don't
think that they were Leanne was saying
that all the women and men that they saw
in those clubs doing those shows were
like sold in to select slavery and are
working for human traffickers yeah when
I think it's just a common job it's like
us being a stripper in America I have no
idea I have no idea but they were just
speaking like as if it was facts yeah
but someone should have like supplied
the faculty I would love a Wikipedia
quick search right I feel like Andy
could have stepped in been like no it's
legal maybe it's both perhaps I'm just a
great season to Dallas honestly like
yeah really picked up I didn't think it
was gonna be mm-hmm what it turned out
to be and I think Kerry burning ham was
such a great addition and I just like
her so much I like her so much I love
her friendship with DeAndre and with
Cameron hammered um I need Cameron
Stephanie and brandy to just like come
together what was really interesting was
that when they all had to apologize to
one another everyone opposed to Gary
LeAnn for what she said Cameron and
Stephanie for not telling her sooner
brandy also like everyone apologized to
her it was like so sad yeah I mean she
does she needed it I can't imagine how
she must have felt watching it and
having to talk about it having to talk
to this person who's had those things
about her like I and be confronted with
just looking one yes season one she is a
veteran now like she she's lived it's
like dog years she's been through seven
reunions yeah I think next year we'll
get a new housewife especially playing
Scott and I look forward to that because
the people that they've been choosing
the new additions have just been better
and better its I just think maybe
whatever production company produces
Dallas is really good at their job
because they have really gotten their
[ __ ] together totally the fourth season
and I think it's better than some other
franchises totally they had a rough
first season with Tiffany and her
husband who looks like Keith Urban but
they got together quick she was gone in
a minute yeah and I just I love DeAndre
I really do I need respect for DeAndre
in like last season we were like
ride-or-die and no one had respect for
her and I'm just really happy for her
I love her and her husband I loved the
way she talked about him and when
someone was a talent to get a job and
she was like [ __ ] you no I completely
agree and I didn't even know he was in
the military maybe I just like wasn't
paying attention but the way she speaks
about him is like so respectful and I
just stand out and also he's incredibly
good-looking right and they just have
such a real and great relationship yeah
um I just can't believe that she has a
trust and that's what something set like
you're 52 like no you just found out
like 21 and you still don't have your
trust and it's like sad for her to talk
about her mother's like impending death
right I was like a good thing no it's so
morbid
um and I feel like her mom should give
her access to the trust just so that
she's not like waiting here to lead okay
so like yeah yeah it's weird but I'm
glad that they're on better terms now me
too I'm glad she turned the business
around I'm happy for HSN Diller I'm
sorry I have two things to say one I
feel like the show was actually really
good for Deanna and her mom's
relationship I think that it mama G
actually respects it and like set
teondra dozen and likes being on it but
to Deandra did say one thing that was
just so incredibly hypocritical like I
couldn't believe it when she was saying
how if she was LeAnn she would have used
that dressing as an opportunity to sell
everyone a dress she's such a saleswoman
literally we still don't on the name of
her company oh yes Deandra should have
used this season to sell everyone her
products not just show us how her
business is failing but show us the
products like show us her using them
getting them to the girls talking about
why it'll be the party talking about why
the business should be succeeding
because the products are so incredible
talking like this master salesman three
smoking years to tell us the name of her
company she missed the biggest sales
opportunity of all time a thousand I can
totally agree and I'm glad that Deandra
and Cary apologized for the dress thing
because that was the only thing I didn't
agree with them about yeah but you know
what it's like when when it's when it's
a male and silly because what Lee Anne
did was so much crazier and worse that
nobody even cares if in certain
situations when Lee Anne was right right
closing the chapter on another good
season of Dallas I'm very pleased I hope
that I do hope that they bring someone
in new I'm really excited for new season
and I just I really like the Dallas
girls and they're also so nice in person
like that helps they haven't become like
you know Vicki Gunvalson yet know no
one's up there saying this is my show so
now that that's over
I think Jersey is almost done well we're
like in the middle of the season because
they gave us that when you
didn't trailer so what's next my New
York something Beverly Hills will be
first they usually film over the summer
in New York is in the fall there's a
time period where New York and Beverly
Hills around at the same time and that's
just like the best time and if sometimes
we get like southern charm as well and
made her Punk rolls runs throughout and
Shahs of Sunset yeah and don't be tardy
yeah okay we got good stuff coming up
I'm excited um anything else no that's
it for me you have a flight to catch
yeah tomorrow's episode will be podcast
only when Claudia gets back from Kansas
City so we're gonna record it later in
the day it won't be up at 10:30
but at 10:30 our patreon episode with
Olivia will be up so if you need that
premium content head over to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast and
then your regular schedule toast will be
available I would say around 2 o'clock
tomorrow it depends when you get in yep
again in at 1:20 so I would say not 2
o'clock we have to record 3 o'clock 3 um
and if you're gonna be in Kansas City
I'm so excited to see you tickets
available Karl's lunch opcom thank you
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennium morning show where
we go up money through out of 10 30 days
some time on YouTube if you're watching
us on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
thank you for watching
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio I
our videocast box wherever you choose to
listen to podcasts listen to us leave a
review
fiestar's embed a comment on how
beautiful setting and smart we are I
don't know it's up to you thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
we love you have an amazing day